[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi aussi j'ai quelque chose à dire dans
quelle famille l'a dit moi c'est un
bâtiment
je suis beaucoup plus connu sur les
réseaux sociaux sous le nom débat si
elle n'en était rien décidé et je suis
en licence en troisième année de licence
aux beaux-arts de cocody mais au prix à
l'arrêt fait une formation au centre des
arts et je me suis imprégné du monde il
a alors l'idée c'est que je puisse
parler de mon domaine en dix ans quinze
minutes vraiment ses passions avec vous
dans les passions et on va les choses et
les expérimentés c'est pas facile mais
je crois que je verrai l'effort
il ya plusieurs points dont j'aimerais
par le premier point c'est nous allons
par un peu numérique et nous avons parlé
des opportunités qui s'offrent aux
artistes avec l'avènement du numérique
il faut dire que le numérique était reçu
dans différents domaines d'activité
comme un événement mais ciel parce qu'il
a permis la révolution de beaucoup cédé
beaucoup de secteurs d'activité même une
on ratisse le numérique nous apporter
beaucoup de choses
le premier élément c'est que le
numérique favorise ce qu'on appelle la
démission rapide et facile de
l'information est cette chose est
tellement important pour une actrice que
j'imagine le mpiq d'assaut et léonard de
vinci après avoir bu ne devra donc des
mois voire des années nous a présentées
lors d'une exposition ses travaux
aujourd'hui moi j'ai la capacité les
dessiner le mardi et dans le soir place
à l'ère du numérique
l'événement
numérique je peux pas nier les personnes
et c'est relayé dans le monde numérique
nous avons été beaucoup de choses en
tant qu'artiste ça nous permet de gagner
en temps de pouvoir se faire connaître
du rapidement d'élargir notre cible que
nous aimerions atteindre et ça permet
aussi l'avènement de ce qu'on appelle de
nouveaux emplois par domaine artistique
par exemple avec une infographie où nous
avons la possibilité non seulement à que
de travailler si les supports
conventionnels mais aussi travailler sur
des supports innovants terminé avec
paris institut alors la raison que je
prends les gangs armés nord
déjà c'est beaucoup plus rapide
d'exprimer une idée si tablette
graphique super j'ai eu mille idées dans
ma tête jamais la saison des semis
l'idée donc si je vais utiliser le veut
j'aurai des amis venus mais ci-jointe
l'avesnois avec du coup ça va rapidement
et je pourrai beaucoup plus simplifié
nombre de mains ça me permet de
préserver mon travail sur ils n'ont duré
deux heures après les derniers temps et
le droit ça me permet aussi de gagner 10
ans et compte tenu du coût aussi de tout
ça il ya un autre point sur lequel
j'aimerais qu'on puisse attardé c'est
que objets les tirs aux dépens de
numérique a permis l'objet l'étonné pas
le numérique permet même une large
diffusion de l'information et rapidement
j'aimerais qu'on puisse mettre la
mémoire des choses
voilà il lâche diffusion eu du travail
qu'on fait et on t'attend c'est
tellement important que les gens
puissent voir en masse avec vous que
vous faites et vous fait alors comme
beaucoup de voix les réseaux sociaux -
on rappelle gribouilleur déjà pour moi
parce que le style que j'utilise pour
représenter les progrès c'est ce qu'on
appelle du gribouillage et les
gribouillages c'est qui consiste à
représenter les personnages avec des
lignes ondulées de manière désordonnée
mais tout ça dans le but de présenter
l'autre dans ses environs l'autre a pâti
des autres voilà parce que moi j'estime
mieux au delà de pousser des hommes nous
présente le monde nous avons fait sortir
fait chaud d'astronomes alors lorsque
j'ai été contacté une main des monnaies
les cigales un moment est ce que je me
suis fait connaître grâce aux réseaux
sociaux etc où ça parce que la grande
patrie de matériel s'est propagé à grâce
aux réseaux sociaux
donc l'idée au début je faisais les
portraits et je faisais le portrait et
je publiais sur les réseaux sociaux pour
inciter les gens à épais comme et est
abonnée à un point de vue et au début je
désigne les individus lambda les biens
sont pas reconnus et je me suis dis
merci
les gens doivent apporter 1 et 2 doivent
aborder les critiques par rapport à ce
que je fais il faut être plus complète
au monde connaît la personne par exemple
si je dessine fille du quartier
un diptyque assez joli même puisque je
connais voir la fiche peut pas
s'entraîner et
visage en parfait de mort ou alors
retenu de ce point de vue je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que je commence à dessiner
des spams parce que les gars allez voir
beaucoup plus il du coup si je fais un
internaute savoir que ça n'a pas souvent
réussi dans lancement mais dans les
détails ou les points ils sont alors
j'ai commencé à dessiner les artistes et
j'ai commencé la première personne j'ai
commencé à devenir des stars des
artistes des pressions ni de personnel
est la première personne que j'ai
regardé signée c'est que les personnages
de l'émission c'est fini de la paire me
manque j'ai d é nice à la nasa
j'ai dessiné et vous voyez comment le
numérique a permis un environnement par
exemple quand j'ai commencé à dessiner
les personnages
les personnages de cette chronique de
ces midi il y à des artistes on commence
avec des envies mode rafale
du coup le travail a commencé de
diffuser partager et voient dénier les
personnes commençaient à voir ce que
j'avais commencé à fait dans ma chambre
est ici c'est eux
dj lewis qui m'avait contacté pour que
je fasse la pochette de son album
mouah mouah mouah particules moi
j'estime que c'est une première de voir
la pochette de l'album fanatisme en
milliards et du poney quand je suis
reste il investit
boyajean pas tu vois pas ce que c'est
une technique très rapide des noms
anciennement et j'ai dû rappeler aux
hommes au pays et qui si j'avais vu à
faire gilles segal shin sekai régime et
où se protéger lui même à passer assez
minime ou rubin vous donnez le cadeau de
kadji cédé lors de son anniversaire
ça c'est une fiente le pdg de la poste
de pdg de la rose voilà donc comme je
disais comment est-ce que ça s'est passé
déjà j'ai mis des jeux vidéo donne avec
les stars et doussain et l'idée est
venue du fait que lors que j'ai fait le
premier portrait d'une personne connue
bd jean michel aulas lui même il a vu
dans l'habitation qu'il a aimée il a
régné sur sa page et beaucoup de
personnes vont venir mais débordante et
donc les maniements la tête et la vie
vraiment du fait du bon travail
j'ai dit ok puisque j'ai déjà réalisé
vos problèmes il serait mieux pour lui
se voit à mes jeux puisque de l'humanité
il évoquait ya pas de problème donc on a
organisé un rendez vous où j'ai croisé
alors l'idée est partie de là je me suis
dit puisque on retravaille père jean
marc germain vie des entreprises
alors j'ai commencé à dessiner les
personnes connues notamment vous avez vu
vous à schiltigheim et toutes les
personnes qui venaient faire le concert
en bonne voie ici j'ai un podomètre imac
portable et vous réalisez les mots de ré
où ça s'est passé alain du numérique
une fois j'étais sur facebook et une
personne mike green manigat bastian
baker
mais pour moi ce que c'est maintenant
est ce parce que en garde et je ne fais
pas ça il ya trois ans de cela il ya
maintenant je suis maintenant je sais
mais ça gagne quand je dessine comme ça
il ya longtemps j'ai accompli des
prouesses
maintenant que s'ils n'étaient pas
passés par le numérique c'est à 10 par
les repas les réseaux sociaux et tout ça
l'information n'était pas réveiller et
du coup je ne pouvais pas atteindre la
cible que je voulais ma peine j'aimerais
vêtements expliqué en moins présent que
nous devons si le cas nous devons nous
attarder
vous savez dans la vie pour pouvoir
progresser est arrivé en haut niveau ne
veut pas négliger ces deux points le
premier point sera fait il est très
important de s'impliquer sur le
savoir-faire voilà pourquoi ne négligez
pas le temps de la formation comprenant
de vous former
impliquez vous appuyez vous former parce
que dans le futur cela sera très
profitable
il ya de ça va faire très très important
mais après le savent à peine il ya ce
qu'on appelle le faire savoir et dans le
domaine du faire savoir
c'est là que nous utilisons le numérique
boulant condamnation de l'information
dont l'os de chialeux ça va faire du mal
à maîtriser
tu rentre maintenant dans le pro du
savoir faire afin d'être diffusé cette
semaine guillaume est ici lorsque j'ai
compris ce principe
j'ai commencé à diffuser à diffuser à
diffuser et vous aller 1 1 cela va
peut-être vous étonner mais je vous
assure que ça va t on d'aller dans des
domaines où je me dirais même pas
imaginer diane est ce qu'aujourd'hui
le de mon parcours je me dis waouh aussi
bouillage une fois jean michel est venu
maintenant pu faire à la maison
et parce que des fois lorsque je vois le
succès le plus sage est bien du mal avec
ce trio risée ou plutôt j'ai du mal à
comprendre en fait l'ampleur de la chose
et jordan a fait de moi même et jeudi à
pau ses gribouillages a aussi guyane ces
choses là parce qu'il arrive que les
gens en tête ont une plus haute opinion
de ce que vous même faites donc les gens
m'écrivent est de la france j'ai reçu
une lettre nous par exemple et le gave
asie je suis frais je suis fier d'être
ivoirien parce que je peux dire méhari
français que négation des faits grâce à
vous donc vous voyez
grâce au numérique il a pu me connaître
et il a pu s'identifier à moi du coup il
a commencé à faire de la pub lire là la
propagande à ce niveau est en ce moment
où je vous parle le gribouillage tourner
dans différents pays et chaque jour
lorsque je me connecte
heureusement les encouragements et des
encouragements et comme personnalité
avec nous le savons gérer leur ont
repris le cooper le président affi
n'guessan bienvenue à le roman
d'ailleurs posé beaucoup d'un dîner mon
arrivée avec changé et pousse à prat
surpris guyane et dans son numérique sur
vous parce que sont le numérique ou
vraiment ça fasse vrai ce serait
raisonnée dans ma chambre
des fois on tire à 4 crois que nous
sommes un peu comme génération à la fois
bénite m'interdis pas pourquoi mais ni
dans le sens où nous avons nous avons
beaucoup d'opportunités aujourd'hui que
vous résiderez je vous assure les
opportunités qui se présentent à nous ne
se sont pas présentés à vos parents mais
je vous assure que beaucoup de nos
parents beaucoup en réussit par rapport
à ceux qui sont à notre démo donc déjà
novembre une autre il ya là un problème
parce que nous sommes une génération qui
étend à notre époque nous avons plus d
éléments à notre disposition au move à
parvenir à la réussite
mais où est ce que la malédiction c'est
christ au ciel lorsque nous n'arrivons
pas à comprendre que tous ces éléments
qui sont mis autour de nous ne sont pas
organisées venues nous distraire
mais en réalité sont venus l'emporter
afin que nous puissions accompli quelque
chose de plus grand mais le problème
c'est que ce que les gens se connaître
l'interrégion utilise le numérique il se
laisse distraire à un tel point qu'ils
ne travaillent plus alors que le
numérique est censé revenir apporter à
bail initial encore plus grand le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui par
exemple vous verrez un élève par exemple
qu'à des devoirs à faire
y'a des gars les choses
mais il sera plus connecté sur facebook
maintenant de haut parfois de faire des
choses qui ne lui serviront peut-être
pas à grand chose
après de parler d'eux ne pourrait rien
de s'avérer des mourides miens pendant
ce temps il néglige un point important
de sa vie
donc les atouts qui se présentent au
moins d'entraînements sont devenus pour
beaucoup une sorte de distraction et les
empêchent même de se concentrer pour
bien des personnes en état et en temps
d'étudier vont rendre le temps de -1
servi de voir une photo ou d'émettre une
obligation mais pendant ce temps là
n'avait pas le temps de vous concentrer
parce que la présentation très
importante donc j'aimerais que chacun
puisse prendre conscience que nous
sommes dans une époque qui nous
favorisent est comme ça déforme on
favorise nous devons prendre en
considération coup c'est la coupe qui
nous sont donnés afin de produire
quelque chose de meilleur est excellent
martin est déplorable de ceux qui ont
vécu dans le passé at on pu beaucoup
plus de choses que la majorité de la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
dès lors pourquoi pas c'est la relève et
coup de chance et fait plus de ceux qui
ont commencé
ceux qui nous ont précédés et ces termes
en déplorant parce que nous n'avons pas
compris ce principe là et que nous ne
nous mettons pas au travail
aujourd'hui nous voulons dire à
quelqu'un que le futur événement le
foetus événements mais quand nous disons
que le foetus est maintenant c'est la
vérité chaque nation je suis même en
raison à rené matte
sidérant le sud pour futures mais le
problème c'est que les gens en quête
d'un futur mais le présent et r je
dirais les présents n'est pas remplie
d'action il est ménée revenus votive
et comme j'ai l'habitude de le dire pour
moi ce que je suis en train de faire
aujourd'hui et je pourrais te dire ce
que tu seras de parce que si aujourd'hui
tu négligent ces témoins aujourd'hui
s'ils négligent ces deux aspects de la
gêne à sucre confiture n'essaiera pas ce
à quoi tu t'imagines pense que le futur
c'est maintenant je ne finis pas une
métaphore
lorsque nous voyons une bonne chose nous
devons savoir que cette grande joie d'un
puisse se matérialiser
il faut qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle faire
les choses ni nature y est plus lorsque
l'on nombreux
[Musique]
par exemple le cas d'un arbre parisot et
lorsque l'on voit un a pour but d'en
voir un grand table etc
nous voyons que cet intrigant mais nous
ignorons du sénat revient d'une toute
petite graine dont finalement j'aimerais
dire à quelqu'un de ne pas négliger sont
présents des mêmes moules et royan place
ou réaliser son futur et la réalisation
de son futur ne commence pas des mêmes
mais la réalisation de son futur
c'est aujourd'hui que tu le construis
est ce que tu as commencé à faire
aujourd'hui ce qui portera les bruits de
main merci des marchés montait
[Applaudissements]